* Treibende Klänge *
Matthias Schmidt
trainiert für einen Triathlon
und ist darum stets
um seinen Kalorienhaushalt besorgt.
Er ist Kadermann bei der Swisscom
und so gut wie immer erreichbar -
notfalls schon vor dem Frühstück.
Es sind
schon zehn Mails aufgelaufen.
Ich habe gerade geschaut,
was für mich wichtig ist.
Aber es ist noch nichts,
bzw. eine Mail war wichtig,
auf die musste ich antworten.
Alles Weitere
schaue ich gleich im Büro an.
Hoi.
Stefan Grötzinger ist
Energiebeauftragter der Stadt Wil.
Ihm wird es manchmal zu viel mit der
ständigen digitalen Verfügbarkeit.
Ja ...
Es gibt einige,
die mir extrem viel schicken.
Sie schreiben sehr viel,
das kann dann ...
Es gab auch schon Zeiten,
in denen es mir zu viel war.
Anina Mutter
hat rund 15'000 Follower.
Das sind 15'000 Menschen,
die sich für alles interessieren,
was sie macht - oder isst.
* Nachrichtenton *
Während des Essens versuche ich, das
Handy wegzulegen, ich drehe es um.
Ich finde es wichtig,
sich aufs Essen zu konzentrieren.
Es ist mein Job,
und er verfolgt mich überallhin,
weil ich ihn
in diesem Ding drin habe.
Ja, hallo?
Anina, hoi. Hier ist Roman ...
Ja, ja.
Du, sorry, ich habe
sowieso gerade viel um die Ohren.
Ich habe keine Zeit,
mich riesig mit der Innovation einer
neuen Kampagne zu beschäftigen.
Bis dann, tschüss.
Ich hasse telefonieren.
Und alle rufen mich an.
Ach.
Man kann mir eine Mail schreiben,
ich bin nonstop online.
Ach so, das ist gut.
Du bist nicht im Hub, oder?
Schmidt arbeitet oft
im sog. Pirates Hub der Swisscom.
Hier hat keiner mehr
einen fixen Arbeitsplatz.
Wichtig ist nur,
dass man sich einloggt -
und das geht ja überall,
auch zu Hause.
Anina Mutter
ist Schauspielerin und Model,
v.a. aber auch Bloggerin
und Internet-Persönlichkeit.
Ein Beruf mit Zukunft, sagt sie.
Oft wird
die Digitalisierung verteufelt.
Ich finde, dass man einerseits mit
dem Konsumieren vorsichtig sein muss
und dass es im Leben, im Alltag
sehr invasiv sein kann.
Aber es gibt mir auch die Möglich-
keit, von zu Hause aus zu arbeiten,
mein Ding zu machen,
völlig unabhängig von allem
selbstständig zu arbeiten.
Das ist schon
ein unglaublicher Wertgewinn.
Wenn ich mit einem Nine-to-five-Job
im Büro sitzen müsste,
wäre das mein Tod.
Grötzinger ist verantwortlich
für den Zukunftstag
Mobilität und Energie der Stadt Wil.
Ziel: für smarte Lösungen
sensibilisieren.
Im Schulhaus gibt es
virtuelle Realität und Smart City.
In der virtuellen Realität
können schon Kinder
das Auto ihrer Eltern so optimieren,
dass es weniger Treibstoff
verbraucht.
Hier geht es Richtung Zukunft -
mit Vollgas und digital.
Heute wäre ich wohl
etwas nervös geworden ohne Handy.
Viele mussten mich noch erreichen.
Aber im Ausland, auf Reisen,
wenn ich kein Netz habe,
bin ich auch froh,
eine Zeit ohne Handy zu erleben.
Schmidt weiss, dass es nur
die Wenigsten geniessen können,
keinen Empfang zu haben.
Hallo, Daniel. Morgen.
- Hallo, Servus.
Darum arbeitet die Swisscom daran,
dass wir künftig überall Netz haben,
auch auf den höchsten Bergen
und in den tiefsten Tälern.
... und wie weit
sollte man damit gehen?
Schmidt, der daran mitarbeitet,
sehnt sich indes nach mehr Momenten,
in denen er offline sein darf.
Was ist das Schönste daran,
mal nicht erreichbar zu sein?
Ich glaube, für mich ist es:
die Zeit einmal Zeit sein zu lassen
und sich nicht von einer Minute
auf die nächste zu hetzen.
Sich mit sich beschäftigen.
Die Digitalisierung ist für Schmidt
und viele andere ein Stressfaktor.
Was vor 30 Jahren richtig anfing, hat
offensichtlich auch Schattenseiten.
(Originalkommentar)
Im Herbst 91 fällt der Startschuss
für ein europäisches
Mobiltelefonsystem,
in der Schweiz Natel D genannt.
Hauptakteur
im europäischen Mobiltelefonmarkt
ist der schwedische Konzern Ericsson,
mit 70'000 Beschäftigten
und 10 Mrd. Fr. Umsatz
einer der international Grossen
in der Branche.
Taschentelefone
sind das Hauptprodukt.
Der Betrieb Kumla produziert sie
für verschiedene Mobiltelefonsysteme
in aller Welt.
In 50-60 Jahren könnte man sich ein
Gerät in dieser Grösse vorstellen,
einen Drittel so gross
wie das von heute.
Damals war unsere Gegenwart
noch Science Fiction.
Aber man konnte sich vorstellen, dass
sich Grundsätzliches ändern würde
und versuchte,
die Bevölkerung darauf vorzubereiten.
(Originalkommentar) Das Ziel
heisst Personal communication.
Was ist damit gemeint?
Wer heute telefoniert,
ruft nicht Personen an,
sondern fest installierte Telefone,
z.B. im Büro, der Wohnung
oder im Ferienhaus.
* Klingeln *
Und das ist Personal communication:
Jeder Mann, jede Frau hat
eine ganz persönliche Telefonnummer.
Zur Personal communication
gehört ferner
ein persönliches Taschentelefon,
das alle auf sich tragen.
Dieses Telefon ersetzt
die bisherigen Telefonapparate.
Für mich persönlich
bedeutet es totale Freiheit.
Ich bin nicht mehr
an den Tisch gebunden,
ich kann mich
im ganzen Büro bewegen.
Ich kann auf die Strasse
oder gar nach Hause gehen.
Trotzdem kann ich dabei
anderen zur Verfügung stehen.
Dazu kommt,
dass das Gerät diesen Knopf hat:
Man kann es auch ausschalten.
Das gehört auch zur Freiheit.
Von MTW arrangierte Szenen
in einem Zürcher Restaurant.
Ein Esslokal
voll telefonierender Mitmenschen.
Heute Fiktion, morgen könnten
solche Bilder zum Alltag gehören.
Am Mittagstisch die gestresste
Fortsetzung der Morgengeschäfte.
Für das persönliche Gespräch
unter Kollegen bleibt kaum Zeit.
Der Traum
von der totalen Kommunikation,
pervertiert zum Albtraum.
Fazit: Wir müssen lernen, die totale
Kommunikation zu beherrschen.
Andernfalls wird sie
in Zukunft uns beherrschen.
* Ruhige Klänge, Vogelzwischern *
# (Frauen, monoton) Laa.
Stell dir beim Ausatmen vor,
wie sich die Sonnenstrahlen
in deinem ganzen Körper verteilen.
Mit jeder Einatmung
wächst die Sonne,
mit jeder Ausatmung
verteilen sich die Sonnenstrahlen
in deinem ganzen Körper.
Jetzt fliegen.
Sie alle haben ihre Handys abgegeben,
um endlich mal weg vom Netz
und näher bei sich zu sein.
Dann verbinde dich
mit deinem Nachbarn.
Finde einen Fokuspunkt,
in die Weite.
Komm zurück zur Mitte,
atme tief ein.
Und dann bleib stark in der Mitte,
während du den Fuss hinten ablegst.
Für mich geht es immer darum,
Körper, Geist und Seele in
einen gewissen Einklang zu bringen
und Gesundheit grundsätzlich
mit in den Alltag zu nehmen.
Auch darum, seine Ruhe zu finden.
Nicht nur
das Kurzfristige zu optimieren,
sondern das Ganze zu sehen.
Eine gewisse Langfrist in die
Perspektive einfliessen zu lassen.
Eine Hütte oberhalb von Kandersteg
ist für die nächsten Tage
ihr Zuhause.
Der Berner Oberländer Tourismus
hat die gestressten Städter
als Zielgruppe entdeckt
und offeriert neuerdings
ein sog. Digital Detox Camp.
Digital Detox - ein Modebegriff,
der digitales Entgiften bedeutet.
Es wird konsequent auf alle elektro-
nischen Empfangsgeräte verzichtet.
Man legt das Handy weg
und beschäftigt sich
unter professioneller Anleitung
mit sich und seiner Umwelt.
Ich war schon eine Weile
nicht mehr in den Bergen.
Durch die ganzen Eindrücke vermisse
ich das Handy absolut nicht.
Jetzt schon nicht.
Es gibt ja Momente, in denen man
an die Hosentasche greift
und schaut, ob man es noch hat.
Aber dieser Effekt
ist nicht gekommen.
Das ist sehr schön -
ich war vertieft in Gespräche.
Es gab keinen Moment,
in dem ich darauf schauen wollte.
Alle Teilnehmer
waren vor einem Jahr schon mal hier.
Jetzt treffen sie sich
zu einer Reunion
und zu einer erneuten Auszeit
vom digitalen Alltag.
Keiner von ihnen
möchte die Digitalisierung missen,
aber manchmal
wachse ihnen alles über den Kopf.
Es sei oft schwierig,
sich abzugrenzen.
Das Handy dauerhaft abzugeben,
ist aber keine Option.
Als orthodoxe Offliner
wären sie gar nicht vermittelbar
in ihren Berufsfeldern.
Ich habe mir vorgenommen, mich mal
auszuklinken, irgendwohin zu gehen
und die Bergwelt
auf mich wirken zu lassen.
Das möchte ich bewusst tun.
In dieser Übung
geht es um Achtsamkeit.
Schmidt und Co. sollen versuchen,
die Welt mit allen Sinnen
bewusster wahrzunehmen.
Das können sie später in den Alltag
einbauen und so Stress abbauen.
Wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt?
Wie fühlen Sie sich?
Sehr gut.
Es ist schon interessant, aus der
Geräuschkulisse etwas mitzunehmen.
Die Füsse sind ganz kalt,
die Nasenspitze
wird von der Sonne gewärmt.
Die verschiedenen Untergründe kann
man schon auf sich wirken lassen.
Mal sind sie schon schmerzhaft,
bei spitzen Steinen.
Im Wasser merkt man, dass auch
viele runde Steine dabei sind,
die sich dem Fussbogen
ganz gut anschmiegen.
Es sind sehr viele Sinne
und Impressionen,
die angesprochen werden.
Anina Mutter
ist eine Art Online-Werbeträgerin:
Firmen zahlen ihr Geld,
damit sie ihren Followern
gewisse Produkte präsentiert.
In diesem Fall nachhaltig
und fair produzierte Kleider.
Wie sieht das denn aus?
Ich kann aufzeigen,
dass faire Mode schon lange nicht
mehr öko und Vollkorn sein muss.
Es gibt durchaus
auch stylische Stücke.
Das gehört zu dem,
was ich als meine Aufgabe ansehe.
Top.
Eine befreundete Fotografin knipst.
Und Mutter verdient daran,
die Bilder später online zu stellen
und mit einer subtilen Werbebotschaft
zu versehen.
Der User
will was sehen für seinen Klick.
Mutter liefert mit Ganzkörpereinsatz.
Mach es noch mal.
Dann die Beine mal auseinander.
Aber auch sie wird nicht jünger.
Bei einem Flickflack auf Beton -
ja, da fühlt man sich
auch mit 30 schon fast wie eine Oma.
Und wie ist man
bei Instagram mit 30 dran?
Eine gute Frage. Gerade Instagram
finde ich offen für alle.
Die Jüngeren sind sowieso
auch noch auf anderen Plattformen
wie Snapchat und musical.ly usw.
Von daher fühle ich mich
gerade bei Instagram
mit 30 noch nicht wie eine Oma.
Gut.
Du hast wohl
an meinen Daten herumstudiert?
Eine Smartwatch lädt
Schmidts Triathlon-Trainingsdaten
laufend in eine Cloud hoch.
Sein Coach in München analysiert
und interveniert quasi in Echtzeit.
... irgendwie einfach Gas gegeben.
* Eine Frau lacht. *
Das persönliche Datenmeer
als Chance zur Selbstoptimierung.
Wobei auch Schmidt weiss:
Keine Chancen ohne Risiken.
So. Gut.
Man spricht auch
von diesem creepy Moment,
wenn man bei Facebook
mit seinen Kollegen chattet,
über den Friseurtermin spricht,
und dann gleich eine Werbung zum
nächsten Friseur eingeblendet wird.
Zufälle gibt's im Leben.
Vielleicht sind es Zufälle,
vielleicht aber auch nicht.
In diesen Momenten sage ich mir:
"Moment, da stimmt doch etwas nicht,
da liest wer mit
und versucht vielleicht,
mich aktiv zu beeinflussen."
Macht Ihnen das Angst?
Angst macht es mir nicht,
aber es stört mich,
insofern als dass ich
eine direkte Beeinflussung fühle,
die ich nicht akzeptiere
und nicht möchte.
Am Fenster ist es schöner, oder?
Sie ernährt sich vegan.
Das ist kein Geheimnis.
Aber ihre Follower wissen
noch mehr über sie, noch viel mehr:
z.B. wo sie isst,
was sie isst und mit wem sie isst.
Sie lässt die Algorithmen
also sehr weit in ihr Leben.
Bis bald.
- Tschüss.
Wo ist die Grenze?
An der Schlafzimmertür?
Liesse sie sich auch
durch eine Maschine verkuppeln?
Ich bin eine so offene Person,
dass ich auch so
viele Menschen kennenlerne.
Ich muss ...
* Nachrichtenton *
Vielleicht würde ich es probieren,
um zu schauen, wie es ist.
Hoi. Stefan.
Auch Grötzinger
brauchte keine digitale Hilfe
auf der Suche nach der Liebe.
Jetzt, da er sie gefunden hat,
kommt ihm sein Handy
aber ab und an in die Quere.
Okay, bis dann.
Tschau, merci.
Es geht schon los mit dem Filmen.
Permanent. Du musst einfach nicht
in die Kamera schauen.
Nein, aber ich bin überrascht ...
* Spanisches Tanzlied:
"La Macarena" von Los del Rio *
# Eh, Macarena!
Ich möchte ein Selfie machen.
Usain Bolt passt am besten zu mir.
Say cheese! Ich bin schnell
wie der Blitz, wie Usain Bolt.
Haben wir das.
Wir zeigen dir,
welche Technologien dein Leben
in Zukunft verändern werden.
Dieser Roboter heisst Pepper,
hält im House of Swisscom in Basel
wartende Kunden bei Laune
und stimmt sie kauffreudig.
Vielleicht kann er bald noch mehr.
Ich wüsste nicht,
was er für mich erledigen könnte.
Kochen ... Es gibt die,
die so Salat schneiden -
das mache ich lieber selbst.
Zusammen fernsehen?
- Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Über Probleme reden?
- Über Probleme reden?
Da habe ich bisher
noch meine Freunde,
mit denen ich mich lieber
auf einen Kaffee treffe.
Ich berede es lieber mit ihnen,
statt ihm von meinen Sorgen
und Nöten zu erzählen.
Auch wenn er lieb dreinschaut,
bin ich nicht so sicher,
ob er das alles versteht.
In Japan ist das längst Realität:
Roboter ersetzen fehlende
zwischenmenschliche Kontakte.
Etwa bei Senioren.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Jetzt ist die Zeit gekommen,
um einmal einfach zu sein.
Dann strecke mal die Zunge heraus
und lass alles locker im Mund.
Vom Tun gehen wir über zum Sein.
Es gibt nichts zu tun,
und wir sind glücklich darüber,
sein zu dürfen.
Offline zu bleiben ist keine Option.
Ziel ist hier vielmehr
eine Art digitale Selbsterkenntnis:
zu verstehen, was wir
mit der Digitalisierung machen
und was sie mit uns macht.
Und sich konsequenter abzugrenzen.
Man bemerkt seine Reflexe.
Wir sassen zusammen am Tisch,
und ich wollte etwas googeln,
ein Datum in den Kalender eintragen.
Man bemerkt die einzelnen Momente -
aber vermisst ...
Ich finde es schön,
man sollte es wirklich öfter tun.
Three, two, one. Drop it!
* Pulsierende Musik *
Und dann hat der hektische Alltag
sie plötzlich wieder.
Alles kann sich gar nicht ändern,
aber auch nicht nichts.
Sie muss erreichbar bleiben, aber
nicht immer und auch nicht überall.
* Jubel *
Ich habe schon
ein Bewusstsein für Momente,
in denen es wichtig ist,
das Handy mal wegzulegen.
Ich versuche, das gerade in
der Beziehung besonders zu beachten.
Wenn man im Alltag ist, hat man
nicht viele Momente zusammen.
Die sollte man dann richtig
zusammen geniessen können.
Das versuchen auch Grötzinger
und seine Freundin:
die wenigen gemeinsamen Momente
zu geniessen.
Auch wenn es bisweilen
fast eine Dreiecksbeziehung ist:
Er, sie und das Handy.
Es nervt mich schon manchmal,
obwohl ich selbst auch so bin.
Deswegen verstehe ich es auch,
dass er das Bedürfnis hat,
online und up to date zu sein.
Aber ja ...
Es würde ihm wohl schon guttun,
mal abzuschalten.
Schmidt will für eine Freundin
kochen, und YouTube soll helfen.
Die beiden kennen sich, wie könnte es
anders sein, aus dem Internet.
* Klingel *
Bonsoir, hey.
- Hi.
Come in! How is it going?
- Good, how are you?
Er aus Deutschland, sie aus China,
online zusammengeführt in Zürich.
Was, wenn Sie sich
entscheiden müssten,
einen Geruchssinn
oder Internetzugang zu haben?
Schwer zu sagen.
Wenn ich das rational betrachte:
für den Internetzugang.
Damit kann ich mir
im Zweifelsfall Essen bestellen.
Fast die Hälfte der Schweizer
beantwortet diese Frage wie Schmidt:
lieber online bleiben
als weiter riechen können.
Gleichzeitig wünschen sich immer
mehr Menschen Oasen ohne Anschluss.
In diesem Fall ist mein Telefon
schon im Flugmodus.
Wenn ich zu Hause bin und Gäste
habe, gibt's bei mir keinen Empfang.
Im Moment offline?
- Ja, im Moment bin ich offline.
Egal, wie diese Reise weitergeht:
Mensch sein und leben -
das wird wohl nie nur digital gehen,
sondern immer auch analog.